في المقدمة الليلة ، رفض الروسي مقابل الروسي بوتين
مساعدة
مقاتليه الأكثر قيمة ، الجيش الخاص ،
مجموعة فاجنر على الأقل
وفقًا لرئيس فاجنر الليلة
الذي يشتكي من أن الكرملين
لن يستجيب لمكالماته بعد الآن
لحملني على التوقف.  طلب الذخيرة ،
تم قطع جميع الخطوط الساخنة للمكاتب إلى الإدارات وما إلى ذلك
عني ، لكن Humdinger الحقيقي هو أنهم
منعوا الوكالات أيضًا من
اتخاذ القرارات ،
إنه أمر لا يصدق وقد يكون
مهمًا لأن مجموعة Wagner
بالطبع مسؤولة عن
نجاحات صغيرة حققها بوتين في شرق
أوكرانيا في هذه الحرب ، تقدر الولايات المتحدة
أنه في بداية العام كان هناك
حوالي 50000 من مجموعات فاجنر
تقاتل ولكن في الآونة الأخيرة إذا كان جيني باجوسيان
الذي سمعته هناك ومقاتلوه
يتوسلون لقصف الطاولة
لمزيد من الذخيرة يوميًا تقريبًا في الواقع ، لقد مروا خلال
الأيام القليلة الماضية فقط ،
أطرق جميع الأبواب وأطلق صفارات
الإنذار بالذخيرة والتعزيزات
بالإضافة إلى تغطية الأجنحة لدينا ،
فنحن وحدة مدفعية Wagner PMC
كل يوم ننفذها  المهام القتالية الصعبة التي
تغطي مجموعات الاعتداء في
الوقت الحالي ، ونحن معزولون تمامًا عن
الذخيرة ، تم
قطع كل هذا تمامًا في
الأيام القليلة الماضية فقط ، ثم هذه الليلة هذا
الاعتراف الكبير بأنه لا يبدو أن هناك أحدًا مهتمًا بأن
لا أحد يستمع لأنه يبدو
واضحًا  أنه إذا أراد بوتين أن
يظل فاجنر على رأس الأولويات ، فستكون الأمور
مختلفة ، فلن يتم قطعها عن
جميع الهواتف ، ويشكو جيش بوتين العادي
بالطبع من
أن الكثير قد ذهب إلى
مقاتلي فاغنر حتى الآن ، ها هو جندي روسي
الآن كلهم  تذهب الذخيرة إلى RT
muvsk إلى وحدات Wagner PMC التي يمكنها إطلاق
ذخيرة تكفي لمدة أسبوع في يوم
لا يمكننا تحمله ،
لذا تسمعها الآن روسية مقابل
روسية في معركة للذخيرة
وهذا تحول ملحوظ في الأحداث
خاصة  بالنظر إلى أن
علم فاغنر يرفرف في منطقة شرق باك